[Applause]
[Music]
it's only unlikely a country that you've
only heard about on the Eurovision Song
Contest if you watch the Eurovision Song
Contest but the reality is that Estonia
is a pioneering country in many field
some might even call it the Silicon
Valley of Europe companies like Skype
and transferwise were created in Estonia
this is particularly surprising given
that just thirty years ago Estonia was a
part of the Soviet Union in fact
geographically Estonia situation is far
from being ideal their weather is pretty
terrible and in the winter they have as
little as three hours of daylight every
day plus they also have an ongoing
demographic crisis that they are really
struggling to solve further unlike most
countries the female population of
Estonia is markedly higher than the male
population this means that people find
it harder to find the partner and have
children this is why every year Estonia
maintains a course of population
reduction and yet despite all of this
Estonia is the most technologically
advanced nation in all of Europe in fact
it is the only country in Europe where
access to the Internet is recognized in
the Constitution but what really makes
Estonia getting through our country's
Hall of Fame is its king of residency
[Music]
this means vert a person no matter where
they are from can simply fill out a form
and become a virtual citizen of Estonia
but the question you might have in your
mind right now is but what does that
really mean
today we are going to explain this to
you in this video but first let's have a
quick look at the history of Estonia the
first victims of Vladimir poutine in
1991 Estonia got its independence from
the Soviet Union yes other countries
like Belarus and Ukraine got their
independence at around the same time but
in those countries the new political
establishments have a lot of influence
from the old communists early Estonia
won different their first Democratic
prime minister mark la formed a cabinet
with an average age of just 30 years old
these were young people with new ideas
who had no debt to the old Soviet Guard
and this is how it's turning out opened
their markets to the International
economy they assaulted a capitalist
system and a fairly unique political
system that would become well known for
its minimalism in fact it is this word
minimalism that really describes Estonia
better than any other even their flag is
minimalist and is simply a
representation of their traditional
landscape
[Music]
even their taxation is minimalist and
they have a flat rate tax system this
means that everyone in the country pays
the same percentage of tax no matter how
much they earn in this case in Estonia
the income tax is just 20 percent with
these policies it's easy to see why is
there near attractive foreign investment
particularly from the Scandinavian
countries nonetheless this was still not
enough for them to grow at the rate that
they wanted at the beginning of the
1990s less than half of the population
had a phone in their home further the
infrastructure which was built during
the Soviet era with spar for an
acceptable answer you can imagine this
is not a great setup for a country that
is looking for economic development
since the country had no money to invest
in physical roads they instead decided
to invest in virtual roads the country's
telecommunications infrastructure and
just 15 years later Estonia was the
first country in the world to have an
electronic voting system but hold on for
just a second because all of these
reforms didn't exactly come for free
during these 50 years of forward
progress the Russian minority which used
to rule the country became increasingly
politically isolated this is why in 2007
the Kremlin under Vladimir Putin decided
to act
and this is how the first cyberattack in
history was organized and yes a
cyberattack on a country that relied
heavily on its digital infrastructure
was a big problem during the attack
Estonia lost its administration which
was so dramatic that even hospitals were
not able to function this is why since
that day NATO has added cyber security
headquarters in Tallinn the Estonian
capital but this was not the end of
Estonia's problem the financial crisis
two years later in 2009 the financial
crisis struck Estonia hard the country
was particularly exposed because of all
its foreign investment all of a sudden
the country had no money Plus this was
the time when they were supposed to
adopt the euro as their currency so even
if they wanted to make the switch to the
euro they didn't have the funds to make
that happen so the government had two
options they could either cut their
spending or they could raise taxes
unlike other countries like Spain
Estonia took the first option in a
matter of months the government fired
over 10,000 workers this was about a
third of their entire staff politicians
lowered their salaries and froze all
state investments which included many
construction projects all of these cuts
caused the Estonian GDP to fall by a 14
percent in fact year to make a
comparison in their worst year during
the financial crisis the u.s. saw their
GDP fall by 8 percent nonetheless after
going through a terrible 2009 Estonia
sorest economy it begins to improve
almost immediately since they didn't
raise their taxes and business policies
remained very flexible many of those who
lost their jobs decided to start
companies so now let's have a look at
their unemployment chart between 2008
and 2009 Estonia went from a 4 percent
unemployment rate to a 19 percent
unemployment rate at the time that this
was the highest unemployment rate in all
of Europe even higher than Greece and
Spain
however in just two years they cut this
figure in half and now they have an
admirable 6 percent unemployment rate
and the same goes to their salary today
a person working in Tallinn is likely to
be making more money than most people in
southern Europe in summary Estonia is a
model for other countries to follow and
now we can have a look at the key
aspects of this country which didn't
make it quite so successful
till administration it's only a
pioneered the idea of creating a digital
ID card now many other countries have
been copying this models but it's not
something that has ever been as
successful as it was in Estonia the
reason that it is so successful in
Estonia is because this ID card is
actually useful for instance during the
elections any Estonian citizen can take
this LED card go to any computer and
vote electronically from wherever they
are there is no need for any sort of
registration and this is incredibly
useful if you are on holiday during an
election or if you are someone who lives
abroad every expat knows the hassle of
voting while abroad having to go to the
embassy and cast the ballot it's all a
big headache further in addition to all
of this hassle there have been cases
where votes from abroad have simply been
lost so that in Estonia you can use this
ID card to do any sort of government
business and that includes paying your
taxes and forget about all of those long
forms that are the tax authorities make
it
in Estonia you can do everything from
your mobile phone in a matter of minutes
in fact the government has access to the
banks so they can simply find your
income this happens in every other
country including the US the only
difference is that in Estonia they think
it's stupid to ask the same question
twice so you simply go over you're
citizen profile concern with
everything's correct and pay your taxes
just like that but hold on for one
minute because the best is yet to come
imagine that an unscrupulous government
employee wants to spy on your personal
data well then when that happens you
will get a notification on your
government profile you can even see
exactly who that government employee is
who is looking at your data and then if
you want you can ask them why they
aren't doing it
this means that Estonia in this regard
has way more transparency than any other
democracy but if you still think this is
not enough here's the part that really
puts Estonia over the pan if Sounion II
we've all heard about those big
companies that place their fiscal
headquarters in places like Panama or
Luxembourg however this kind of tax
structure is almost impossible for a
freelancer or an SME but if in
Luxembourg and if you want to start a
company in Luxembourg you have to go you
have to start by going to the notary and
to go to the notary it's a two-three
weeks to get an appointment and then you
have to pay a lot of money and there's
an awful lot of bureaucracy and
everything like that well in Estonia
they realized that they needed you
citizen as I said the country faces a
demographic crisis and well their
weather suck that is why in 2014 they
decided to offer their cutting-edge
infrastructure to the whole world no
matter where you come from and so you
might now wonder why is this quite so
useful
now of course this is not the same as an
actual citizenship and you can't use the
residency as a passport but it is a
digital identity issued by a European
government and this certainly helps if
you want to make international
transactions or open a bank account in
Estonia this might be particularly
useful if you are watching this video
from places like the Ukraine Orwell
Venezuela the virtual card also makes it
very easy for you to establish a company
in Estonia and you can do that without
having to move there or do a lot of
complicated paperwork okay well now I
hear you saying
estonia's got to be a fiscal haven right
well actually no corporate tax is 20
percent which is the same as Finland for
example what Estonia really offers is
two main things simplicity and rule of
law now mainly you think that is too
little to offer but the reality is over
10,000 people have already signed up for
this virtual residency one of them is
actually the japanese prime minister
shinzo are they
in other words Estonia has invented a
brand new concept the concept of liquid
citizenship and now here is our big
question for you do you think other
countries will follow the Estonian model
do you think there is a time when
everyone will want to embrace this
Sounion citizenship you can leave your
answer in the comment section below and
do not forget that we put our brand new
videos every Monday and Thursday and
that you should subscribe to this
channel if you want to get those there
will be a logo on the screen now that
you can click or throw a button below
the video and hey if you enjoyed this
video please do give it a thumbs up
below and as always I'll see you next
time I get home this afternoon I'll get
back to the hotel this evening I'm going
to open a bank account start my company
and become an active you to Sony
[Applause]